I'm a sucker for ice cream coffee it's
beer last year last night that's fine it
was a week holy hot doughnuts I'm not
gonna write on my sheet yeah look at
that face that is a face of delicious
first thing of the day protein shake she
says it's nasty I like it yeah I'm look
at that face that is a face of delicious
I wasn't consistent on the staffs
posting system of diet Nina is not
consistent on her diet she's fairly
consistent but she cheats no it's beer
last year last night that's fine it was
always holy path you don't want to lose
too fast to come then you came back easy
brary gimme what are we getting donuts
cream nah we accidentally coordinate it
today Nina's gutter believe hoodie on
I've got mine on too I guess well we're
changing we came out oh we're twins I'm
taller and your life and I'm white
you're Chinese you know but apart from
my with twins usual breakfast coffee
gopher the for the coffee's i went from
the top
and keith green future for coffee in a
large copper tube one sugar two and milk
and that's been coming this way look at
that huh this hash browns are huge today
I came downstairs because the whole
house smells amazing and I'm getting
super hungry what are you making oh my
god so amazing and then eggs hit with
the tries to brio me Nina's cooking made
me so hungry it's not ready yet but i
gotta eat and I luckily still have some
of my pumpkin snacks so I'm going to eat
some of these fill the fuel up a little
bit and then hopefully enjoy some yummy
yoona cooking dinner time kind of lunch
we didn't really eat lunch we woke up
late are we eating chicken and broccoli
and prices I get chicken broccoli oh and
eggs under the game I'm so hungry how
you feeling nervous all right be dddd
dddd alright just gonna go into my class
got to work on my steps does it all have
enough oh one class I'm teaching over
today
so we're playing the catch up game just
got back it's nine o'clock fun foss fun
dancing after but i still need 70 grams
of protein 70 grams someone i also had
on my steps only about eleven thousand
eight hundred so i had 20,000 steps and
70 more grams of protein in three hours
a two big things of pork chop two big
pork chops and a little bit of protein
drink to get to my wow ok let's do it
got three hearts and go this is what I
have to eat such an that bag I thought
it'd be worse I think I doable all right
12 more grams of protein to hit my goal
is eleven o'clock at night that should
be doable oh my steps doing 18 809
alright that's that's doable i can do
top on this episode now I get it
everything Nina's gonna do some stuff
sensing you to comments she loves you
people YouTube she loves you d 15
starting usual start to the day got my
protein 2 cups of lentils an egg and a
certain of the day here we go all right
next up is the meanest smoothie a my
voice kind of cracked Allah said that
very exciting alex is laughing at me
lunchtime I gotta tell you those lentils
fill me up so much I ain't I've lead
eating so late it is 226 I mean in life
now we've got chicken broccoli and bok
choy looks like i messaged nina is the
chicken lunch chicken 60 grams yes thank
you love you okay we're about an hour
away from leaving to go to the workout
class and figure
a little bit more in me so I grabbed a
bowl of Nina's homemade granola with
some almond milk we got almond granola
nuts and seeds and raisins and some
yummy that's the Alex on the side
they're working away when I were to go
then work our class we have a new
assignment cup of carbs per meal more
where for me now except I helped bring
everything in Yeah right and there's
lifting and and I and I pull the visa
from the wallet to purchase that's not
about like the mean card is right heavy
stuff the heavier stuff since you guys
step follow the protein ruled quite well
and you've been pounding it down like a
champ oh you don't see girls every day
so my guess so much media but do you
feel full as you for you so your new
ruger carbs for a decent half couple men
11 out of temple on work then why can't
they just get us here man we millwright
Avenue what about an on workout days
it's not work at these stripes you wanna
cut a house I didn't happen it's been
awesome and for you just cut that it has
yeah and then you can either replace
that with vegetables as well if you get
hungry all depart on those vegetables
like receivers like broccoli carrots
forget it well actually what you do
today I've been pretty close
let's just you got a member on on non
burner a days is half and I'm workout
days it's that's gotta figure that right
I think you gotta we're gonna get it
we're gonna get it okay their time and
I'm super full Nina's gonna have soup
what is this that's sooo yeah this is
having soup and this is pork and salad
and I'm having pork soup salad let's dig
in I feel a little bit peckish so I
grabbed the handful of nuts nothing
right on my feet good morning yesterday
I hit twenty thousand two hundred and
thirty steps and as usual certain the
day protein shake I started on my
breakfast without making a video what if
you usually guys used it by now lentils
and eggs the new thing is about carbs so
it's a day off of a workout this is have
a cup and a half of carbs for the day
and this is two cups of lentils so that
should be it for the day basically it's
filling slowly getting there but
enjoying and just able to step into a
hangout with that Tim Schmoyer super
excited okay I just arrived at alex's
place Alex like coffee smelling amazing
yeah I'm gonna have some okay what are
you making my ice cream coffee o the
Irish cream it's killer man sorry haha
i'm a sucker fresh cream puffs it's so
good with Bailey's man anyway no baby's
gonna kill the 30 day challenge not
having Bailey's so I'm having a large
cup of coffee there with two milks and
one sugar I feel like more could go in
the cuff I feel like you kind of cheap
enough in the coffee like look at all
that space and take it to the rim Oh
feel like Alex a little scary
transferred our gear up at all that's
how much you appreciate that coffee of
and that's it that's a compliment that's
a compliment right right
d there you go look at that that's what
I'm talking about that's an appreciation
and alex is using the mug that i got in
from seattle which is the very first
from the very first starbucks ever
created I know this mom he insisted that
i buy it for himself I was gonna buy
anything for him to be honest but then
we said that's not I had to get him at
least at least I notice appreciate it so
now I feel good all right time to have
some lunch some chicken with some
spinach ready go boeing is smoothie time
because Nina couldn't finish hers kale
yeah okay it's a little bit late we had
a busy day when it's dinnertime chicken
and potatoes we have to add some carbs
even though I'm at my limit and spinach
how was it I mean Nina's a little bit
hungry I'm starting to a little hangry
so we're just gonna eat that's it day 17
here we go woke up by 5am this morning
don't know why but I'll have to get done
anyway I start today usual protein shake
of the day begins
breakfast time same as usual you used to
it by now it's so hot it's steaming up
the camera can you hungry a little bit
earlier qualities have been up since
five o'clock so i went for some Neenah
granola about two cups and then some
almond milk on top of it okay my tds
just filmed finished filming videos for
the week and I'm going to eat lunch
vintage and potatoes and chicken I'm
supposed to have extra cars but I had
cereal i'll still probably eat them in
Ulan all right dinner time I snuck a
cappuccino with one trigger at the car
dealership red early today Nina didn't
want one oh well the woman came up and
gave it to me so oh there was a woman
there too huh you add alex is here
causing problems what else is new and
different time is ground beef and
spinach look at him okay oh look at look
at this look how much man ground beef
does not have enough protein look how
much ground beef II need to eat to get
60 grams of protein that's crazy all
right there 18 welcome welcome usual
start with a smoothie little shake-up on
the lentils Oh Nina added some ground
beef to the top here excited 7 of the
day smoothie time don't know what's in
it but it's green so it's Kayla based
just finished an awesome hang out that
I'm super pumped about online had
pedigree questions so I was running on
fumes and I'm hungry cuz it's two
o'clock lunch time is chicken and
spinach time to get in my belly so I
don't know if it's just my body getting
used to the protein or not I used to be
like massively fullick arcade eat
anymore the protein was just too much
and now maybe I just got used to it
because I find myself saying it's not
enough that I'm hungry
oh we have this healthy stuff it's
Nina's homemade granola with nuts and
with almond milk and I guess talked to
ace and Sean and see what they take get
some wisdom so we just got back from
China dance salsa and I had to get a bar
because I was hungry I got a quest bar
we're both getting hungry during the day
more and we're eating more than before
yeah so know what that's all about we're
gonna do my day yeah anyway we gotta go
with dinner it's late to sign a clock
with you doing fish what's good in it
tilapia fabia ah mmm YUM all right there
time tilapia and spinach most like
10,000 steps behind my goal it's nine
o'clock so i got it 930 holy caps i get
some serious stuffing / running to hit
my goal it's a rushed into the day
hopefully coming good morning dean
nineteen another day with a shake twenty
two thousand three hundred and eighty
six steps it was a crazy dash and i'm
excited for another day it's a friday
right now lots to do super excited next
up back to the usual breakfast friday
morning ritual you guys brought me a
caramel macchiato there it is thursday
right away you're in it that's you bro
that's you celebrity feeling the love in
the caffeine excited alright lunchtime
got i think some leftovers from
yesterday so I'm tilapia and spinach and
is an egg here in the side I'm gonna
have any smoothie while I get the car go
pick up hayden and have some fun tonight
alright it's dinner time we're having
tuna and eggs kbzk his carrots yummy
carrots mmm a little bit behind I ate
some of my hayden he didn't finish his
dinner so I had a little piece of his
pork which is about 10 grams protein
still behind some having another protein
drink and this will put me way over my
total but I know
animatic alright day 20 another day of
the protein shake ready to get started
saturday morning tradition tim hortons
i'm having my usual breakfast sandwich
two coffees I am 11 sugar to milk Nina
what are you doing just one sugar but
one cream okay Nina's got a chili he has
a lot more protein with a lot this is
heaven bread go to hello and hayden is
having what there you go on hash fan and
to timbits you might show us which ones
haha alright Hayden is also rocking his
new hoodie today
alright we're driving to the Metro
Convention Center for an interior design
show we haven't eaten much we are
getting angry getting angry Nina's going
to take over the camera and show you
what she's made for us to eat this is
Evans lunch a shaky a lot because we're
in the car event and Evans driving my
crazy just kidding so this is one and
half can of tuna with two eggs and some
I cut us on spinach and salaries and mix
it together yummy Bon Appetit guys it's
probably pretty scary you're rushing to
go see a movie Ip Man 3 we gotta get
there a super quick and Nina made dinner
for us that went eat in the car as we
get there and we're gonna meet Louie one
of my buddies entrepreneurs what are we
eating what cup with mushrooms and any
oh my god smells so good yeah 20 grand
cuz that's what i need and evan has a ba
degree 80 hands 80 tons of pork holy cow
you're gonna have to see it as a job yum
yum yum here we go
alright day 21 sunday morning means its
way in day excited look who joined us
hey Nev is gonna go first one 27.5 went
to one 23.6 121 22.7 and it's gonna get
on and to go to there she goes one 21.5
my time I went from 20 6.6 the 2004 92
190 5.51 93.7 not the not the biggest
job compared to other weeks but that's
the cheats in there has an extra car of
them anyway gotta stay focused for last
week of the diet ok that's it I'm
Saturday